à deux pas du château de versailles plus
de 2 100 féminine participe ce dimanche
30 mai au triathlon de la reine rendez
vous organisé à l'occasion de la 11e
édition du versailles triathlon festival
un cadre insolite qui séduit toujours
les sportifs c'est magnifique ça donne
encore plus envie de bad est de bien
courir de bien nager parce que parce que
c'est bon alors on est en idées doit
aussi le cadre est super sympa j'avoue
là on n'a pas le temps de regarder quand
on fait la course on est trop focus
au programme pour les filles 750 m de
natation dans la pièce d'eau des suisses
18 km de vélo sur le circuit nexter
systems et 5 km de course à pied pour
terminer sur un chemin les exigeant
parce qu'il ya des dénivelés parce que
tout le début du parcours et à monter
parce que il n'y a pas mal de relances
sur le parcours vélo et à pied c'est pas
si simple non plus on est sur un
revêtement qui va être parfois un petit
peu un petit peu instable sur des
chemins et puis avec une bosse à
apprendre à prendre deux fois c'est
finalement en bronze grâce et qui aura
été la plus à l'aise sur ce parcours ce
jour là la pensionnaire du club d'issy
triathlon s'impose grâce à un screen
dans la dernière ligne droite son chrono
une heure 11 minutes et 11 secondes je
suis contente c'était une belle bataille
avec solène on va faire un bon truc par
équipes la yole camara qui vient
d'arriver
je suis content en bosnie le rendez vous
reviendra l'année prochaine pour une
douzième édition l'événement devrait une
nouvelle fois être organisée au mois de
mai
[Musique]